sopra quelques chiffres c'est incroyable
un sopra 3 nrj music awards
six albums 1,4 million d'abonnés sur un
stade comme je les dis 1,7 milliard de
vues sur youtube 3,6 millions de j'aime
sur sur facebook
voilà c'est un carton sopra comment
comment ça va toi c'est parce que c'est
un truc de ouf la fois je voyais ton âge
c'est que sopra ta 41 ans quand vas tu
vas faire quarante et un koala c'est
comme pharrell williams vieilli par quoi
comme pharrell williams et c'est
incroyable comme jeudi sur scène souvent
b coachée rigole tout le temps d'étudier
c'est ça c'est dans là c'est vrai faut
savoir garder ses palaces en deux ans
elle sourit quand elle sourit tout le
temps
elle souffre elle est exceptionnelle bon
tu qui franchement on est tellement
content que ça marche pour toi et se
prend il ya un autre qui tient à coeur
on voulait absolument parler ce soir
c'est une association
cette association la fondation soprano
elle s'est engagée un appel de fonds
suite au passage du cyclone
kenneth dans les comores donc on a une
petite vidéo à vous montrer qui est très
importante pour nous et juste après on
relèvera un défi toi moi et doc gynéco
oui malheureusement regarde et on sait
que c'est hyper important pour toi et
donc pour vous aussi regarder si vous
aimez sopra ci est franchement cette
vidéo vous allez voir elle va vous
toucher quoi qui la regarde
bonjour sur palm en bon jour serena no
mercy sauf allemand tu sais tu fais
comment pourquoi j'ai sérieux de
réhabiliter les écoles étant ce qu'elle
est
nous avons touché mais tempère et des
mamans ne sont plus touchés dans le sens
pas que dans les dégâts que l'on
remercie sûr pas long merci à toute
l'équipe des pmp et nous comptons soit
on va ce sera le w3c cette panne au
point comme on se prend à vider mon
sopra directement tu vois tous les
enfants comme ça c'est vrai que je sais
que c'est un mec de coeur et je voulais
absolument qu'on parle de ça aujourd'hui
avec toi parce que lorsque cartonne et
je sais que c'est aussi un truc que tu
perds jamais de vue avait déjà merci
d'en parler savez pas vous allez me
passer une vidéo comme ça c'est en fait
ça fait ça fait un mois il ya eu un gros
cyclone qui arrivés aux comores qui a
fait un peu dévasté un peu tout sur son
passage
surtout certaines écoles et ça fait
depuis un mois les enfants ne vont plus
à l'école avec du coup j'ai pensé mais
aussi associé avec l'unicef pour essayer
de de créer une grosse cagnotte pour
pouvoir réhabiliter ces écoles il faut
que ces enfants rentrent très vite à
l'école parce que je trouve que le plus
important c'est l'éducation et je pense
que surtout dans des pays aussi pauvre
l'éducation c'est quelque chose très
importante primordial donc c'est pour ça
qu'on on a lancé depuis deux semaines
cette ombre lunaire est exacte de
réhabiliter les échos alors